les premières rames du tram 13
commencent à circuler ile-de-france
mobilité et la sncf ont lancé les essais
dynamiques
si tout se passe comme prévu la mise en
service aura lieu à l'été 2022 l'idée
c'est vraiment de tester l'ensemble du
système de transport donc les voir sur
lesquelles circulent le tram l'arrivée
en station
l'alimentation électrique par la ligne
aérienne de contact
le système de freinage vous l'avait dit
et aussi la traversée surtout des
carrefours mais carrefour routier
traversées piétonnes que le tram soit
bien pris en compte à la traversée des
carrefours entre lisière pereire à saint
germain en laye et saint cyr l'école le
nouveau tramway empruntera des voies
déjà existantes qui ont été réhabilités
sur ces voies ferrées il pourra adopter
une vitesse plus importante entre en
relation km/heure sur des voies titre en
classique avec la sinisation tran
classique avec toutes les
fonctionnalités du train classique
ensuite on un débranchement on sort de
la partie train pour rentrer en ville et
la duc on passe en mode tramway est là
du coup on a toutes les capacités
performance du tramway pur classique
pour circuler en ville de versailles à
saint germain les la future ligne
traversera des sites remarquables
le projet a dû alors s'adapter afin de
préserver au maximum le patrimoine
historique c'est un tram qui relie donc
le château de versailles et le château
de saint germain en laye et donc avec
des contraintes d'insertion dans le
patrimoine qui sont en forte et il ya eu
un travail qualitatif qui a été menée en
concertation avec l'ensemble des
architectes bâtiments de france des
monuments historiques l'inspecteur des
sites de versailles le tram train
circulera toutes les 10 minutes en heure
de pointe et toutes les 20 minutes en
heure creuse avec une capacité de 250
places dont 88 à 6 et le relire à saint
cyr l'école à saint germain en laye en
30 minutes